Speaker 1: OK. This is very, very interesting.
This is in a way kind of like a Joe Rogan COVID
part to this right winger. Dennis Prager is known
for Prager University, which is a YouTube channel
that puts out a kind of right wing analysis and
interpretations of the world. We've heard that
there are some teachers who even play these
prager u. Videos in classrooms, which is
wholly inappropriate. Dennis Prager is sort of
like this Uber right winger. He's never seen
a right wing position he doesn't like, and he
has been saying a lot of things that don't make
sense about COVID all along. Dennis Prager now has
coronavirus, OK, so he's doing his show from home.
And in this clip, there's a few things we're going
to look at. Dennis Prager has been downplaying
COVID all along. He says in this clip he wanted
to get COVID in order to develop natural immunity,
and he tells us everything is fine. Everything is
no big deal. But he is taking five medications,
including ones that are not proven to do anything
for COVID. And it reminded me of the Joe Rogan
thing where Joe Rogan also said, Listen, the
I'm fine. I felt terrible for a day or two,
but I'm taking. In Rogan's case, I think it was
six medications plus supplements and vitamins,
but this is no big deal. Now, of course, our
question was why would you do that for the flu?
Because if you wouldn't, then clearly this
is more serious than the flu, which many of
these folks deny. So let's just get into the clip.
There's a lot here, there's a lot here, and we're
going to talk in detail about all of this.
Speaker 5: Oh, OK, everybody. All good.
I'm broadcasting from my home, right?
Speaker 1: So by the way, what he did
there was he had he has a cough button. If you're
watching, he just let out a horrifying cough. But
it wasn't audible. Right, right at the top here,
Speaker 5: because I'm not going into the station
as I have COVID. I came I
was tested positive last week
and I have been steadily improving. At no
point was I. In danger of hospitalization.
I have received monoclonal antibodies.
That's Regeneron. I have, of course, four
years a year and a half years been taking
hydroxychloroquine from the beginning with zinc.
I've taken z pack the erythromycin right
as the Zelenka protocol would have it.
I have taken ivermectin. I have done what a person
should do. If one is not going to get vaccinated,
it is infinitely preferable to have
natural immunity than vaccine immunity
Speaker 1: that has not been demonstrated.
Speaker 5: And that is what I hoped for the
entire time. Hence, I so engaged with strangers,
constantly hugging them, taking photos with them,
knowing that I was making myself very susceptible
to getting COVID, which is indeed as bizarre
as it sounded. What I wanted while in the
hope that I would achieve natural immunity
and be taken care of by therapeutics. That is
exactly what has happened. It should have happened
to the great majority of Americans. The number of
deaths in this country owing to COVID is a scandal
which one day will be clear to America.
Speaker 1: So I guess he's saying the COVID
death toll is exaggerated or something like that.
Now the truth is, if we had taken a so-called herd
immunity approach like get as many people infected
as possible. The estimates are that the death toll
would be in the millions already, rather than
the hundreds of thousands. But where do I want
to focus today? Do you take five medications
for something that's no big deal? Do you take
five medications include? I mean, these are some.
Some of these are serious medications. Do you take
this for the flu? Do you take this for a cold? And
clearly you don't. Meaning you are conceding that
this is different and more serious. So let's
talk about them. Monoclonal antibodies, OK?
Monoclonal antibodies appear to be effective at
reducing hospitalization rate and the progression
of severe disease and death when a patient has
mild to moderate COVID in the most serious COVID.
It's not clear that the monoclonal antibodies
help, but in mild to moderate COVID, it does seem
to prevent the progression to more severe COVID.
So monoclonal antibodies? Yes, that's approved by
emergency use. Remember a standard which many of
these folks say is not sufficient for the vaccine,
but they'll gladly take the monoclonal antibodies
under emergency use authorization. Azithromycin,
the z pack. OK, that's an antibiotic. Now he calls
it a erythromycin. That's a different one. This
is azithromycin azithromycin. The data on a zero
Meissen for COVID. The overall quality of evidence
is low to very low, with a conclusion that
azithromycin does not result in superior
clinical improvement in COVID patients relative to
placebo. Azithromycin is generally well tolerated
and safe to use, which we know it's an antibiotic
that's been around for a long time does not seem
to do anything for COVID, but he's taking it
anyway. OK, hydroxychloroquine. Now there are
instances of lots of things that you can find
with hydroxychloroquine. You can find individual
so-called studies, often with sample sizes in
the teens or dozens that may say it might work.
The big picture is that the current body of
evidence does not show a clinical benefit
for prophylactic hydroxychloroquine. That's what
Dennis Prager says he has been doing is as he's
been taking it prophylactically for a year and
a half. And there is a higher risk of adverse
events compared to a placebo or compared to no
prophylaxis. So hydroxychloroquine, now unproven,
doesn't doesn't know evidence it works.
Ivermectin? OK. There is some uncertainty about
whether ivermectin, compared with a placebo or the
standard of care, reduces or increases mortality
in moderately ill hospitalized patients. And many
of the studies have bias as well as imprecision.
It's not even clear a lot of the studies being
pointed to are acceptable. There have been
multiple papers on ivermectin withdrawn after
preprint because they were not rigorously done.
It does not appear as though ivermectin helps
treat COVID. He's taking zinc now. Zinc? OK.
High dose zinc has been studied supplementation,
high dose zinc. It's been studied for colds.
It's been studied and thought about for flu. With
COVID, there is no evidence right now that there
was a significant reduction in the duration of
symptoms for people who are supplementing zinc.
Some studies with the placebo arm specifically on
older patients suggest hospitalized COVID patients
seem to survive a little bit longer with zinc.
It's important to note a lot of older folks are
zinc deficient, so it could be a vitamin D type
situation. It's worthy of a study right now.
There's no causal association found with zinc on
COVID, and we can't say that it actually helps. So
what it might be with zinc is that you need
to treat a ton a ton a ton of people with
super. High dose zinc and have a lot of a lot
of people in that population b zinc deficient
to then find someone who actually survives
altogether because of the zinc, we just don't
know. It's certainly not clear right now that
there's any causal link. So that's what Prager
is taking. Four of the five things he's taking
aren't shown to actually do anything for COVID.
And remember, this is something that's not serious
anyway. It's something it's not serious anyway,
as far as he and many, many others have said so
very confusing. And by the way, I've gone around
hugging people and blah blah blah blah blah.
Who knows what the follow on effects of that
are, and it certainly doesn't seem considerate
to anybody else to be doing that in the middle
of a global pandemic. So that's Dennis Prager,
a man that many people see as a great thinker,
as a great speaker, as a great, um, almost
like a mage of some sort. There are people
who worship this guy, and this is what he's
doing. Taking five medications, four of
which are unproven for something that wasn't
serious anyway. Very, very strange stuff. And
we'll have more on this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.